honestly like this is important we need
to find a meatball the Jersey Shore is
about to lose and oh gee meatball guys I
am retiring from Jersey Shore I am not
quitting a job I am NOT coming back to
Jersey Shore for season four if there is
one that's right on the most recent
episode of her podcast it's happening
with Snooki and Joey
Snooki dropped the bomb she's retiring
from the Jersey Shore and there's a lot
of reasons why it's definitely a hard
decision I love you so much and don't
hate me for my decision but I have to do
what's best for me at the moment and she
doubled down on the message saying she's
definitely sure about leaving the show
adding that right now her life is all
about her three kiddos and her hubby
Jionni I love my babies I love my little
nugget family
Snooki's kids don't actually appear on
the show
so she's seemingly away from them while
filming the show for long stretches at a
time I just can't do it anymore
like literally leaving my kids to film
it is really really hard on me I don't
like partying like three days in a row
it's just not my life anymore and I want
to be home with the kids
that's one reason this has obviously
been on Snooki's mind for a while
she told et this back in 2018 we're
adults now like me and jenni are moms so
like we're 24/7 moms we never go out and
party so when we get with the roomies we
don't have that responsibility we have
crazy just go wild the wild men moms
going wild she also admits she's not
comfortable with the direction the show
is heading I just want to come off as a
good person and lately on the show it's
just been very drama and when it comes
to our show it's not about like Oh team
this team that and then you know fans
are against one another when it comes to
a cast member it's just not how the show
works and that's how it's becoming and I
I don't like the the person that I'm
being portrayed as this is getting a
little too much again it's something
Snooki's been thinking about for a while
we appreciate that old type of drama
this is like let's just say she gets
real
and guys she wasn't kidding Snooki
revealed that viewers are not only
picketing her clothing store but she's
even received death threats right now
I'm just not comfortable filming that
show anymore with the direction it's
going with you know all the drama and
then getting death threats and then
getting death threats to my children
I wanna get so over the drama I thirty
I'm like no we just have fun cuz when I
go home my drama is like my daughter on
the floor like yeah but that's my job
now on the last season of Jersey Shore
family vacation there was a lot of
tension between Snooki's bestie JWoww
and Angelina
Snooki and JWoww were both bridesmaids
in Angelina's recent wedding and
according to an eyewitness they gave a
speech roasting the bride with the
Jersey Shore cameras rolling and
Angelina yeah she wasn't feeling it
Anjali is a show well literal literal
she's interesting yeah we don't hate her
though she's a good time she's a really
good time yes but have no fear yeah
Snooki assured her fans that she isn't
saying goodbye to reality TV forever I
love you guys do not be mad at me
there's gonna be a ton more things you
know that I'll probably be working on
thank God I don't want to live in a
world where Snooki isn't the reigning
queen of reality TV of course you can
count on et to keep you in the loop on
all things Snooki and the Jersey Shore
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
see you soon
[Music]